So now that we know that we have potentially a large number of
measurable features, but maybe a small number of
underlying latent features that contain most of the information.
My question is what we'll be exploring in this lesson.
What's the best way to condense our four features to two?
So that we really get to the heart of the information.
So we're really probing the size and the neighborhood.
One way to get at this is just with simple feature selection,
like with the last lesson.
And if you put these four features into a feature selection tool,
maybe it would keep the square footage, but throw out the number of rooms.
Maybe it would keep the safety and ignore the school ranking.
So here's a little practice quiz.
Which of the feature selection tools do you think would be most
suitable for this?
These are two examples that are both available in sklearn.
Select percentile you're already familiar with,
it just selects the top X percent where you're allowed to
specify the percentage of features that you want to keep.
Another option is SelectKBest and this one's fairly straightforward.
What you do as one of the arguments you specify what k is.
That's the number of features that you want to keep.
So if you put in 10 for k it's going to take the ten best features.
And just to make you think about this a little bit more let me get rid
of the knowledge that we already have for features.
Let's suppose that the number of features you have available to
you isn't something that you know very well.
Say it's one of the first times you're looking at this data set.
But you do know that the size and
the neighborhood are going to be underlying latent variables that are sort of
driving the trends in, in all of the features that you have available to you.
So the question for you is, if you want to have two output features,
what's the most suitable feature selection tool to use in this scenario?
Do you want to use SelectKBest or SelectPercentile?